in this video I'm going to answer some
questions that have been asked to me uh
through YouTube by uh a 16-year-old high
school student who has a strong interest
in philosophy and these questions are
not unique I I actually get uh a number
of questions along these lines coming in
I would say weekly or or monthly so I
think it might be particularly useful
for me to answer them um some of these
have been addressed a little bit in some
of the other videos that I have created
over the years so I'll put links to
those as well but here is the set of
questions and actually I'll just read
the comment more or less for btim um I'm
a 16-year-old high school student and I
haven't really found my passion in
anything except philosophy and maybe art
I was wondering what your opinions were
on trying to Major in philosophy after I
leave high school I know the general
consensus is that a degree in philosophy
is kind of worthless and I don't come
from a particularly wealthy family but
lately I've been thinking about
exploring philosophy and maybe even
becoming a philosophy Professor we don't
really have any philosophy classes at my
school but I feel like I'm at least a
little ahead of the curve with my age
group on philosophical ideals I've
learned at least a bit of stuff on my
own with the help of the internet and
such I suppose it would be a bit biased
to ask someone who enjoys philosophy if
I should pursue it but I feel like
people don't really take the time to try
and comprehend philosophy so they really
wouldn't know in the first place so this
is actually a great set of questions and
observations and I think that um there's
a lot to to say in response to that so I
I isolated out three questions that I
want to
address in terms of um thinking in terms
not necessarily of of giving advice but
at at least of uh giving some sort of
understanding of of what's what's
involved so um should a person major in
philosophy if they're really interested
in philosophy that's question number one
uh question number two that's really
important to take up is a Philosophy
degree kind of or actually
worthless and the third thing is well
what would it take to become a philosopy
professor and is that a viable uh plan
for for one's life so these are all
great questions but before I go into
them I want to address a few other
things that that are coming up in here
but I think are actually really worth
considering so who is the the better
person to ask these sorts of questions
to right does it make sense to ask
somebody outside of the world of
philosophy or does it make more sense to
ask somebody who is so to speak in the
business um does that introduce a kind
of bias um now I would say that ideally
philosophy should be the one place where
you're not going to encounter as much
bias as in other places but I also know
from having worked in the field uh for
such a long time and having been a
student and also you know been a
professor and then moved out of that
into you know what it is that I do today
which is wear a lot of different hats um
you know connected with doing public and
practical philosophy
um I would say that uh philosophers and
people interested in philosophy often
exhibit a lot of bias as well and it's
it's quite understandable as a matter of
fact Aristotle even talks about this uh
when he's talking about people getting
mad when you make fun of something that
they're interested in he brings up
philosophy as an example of that but he
says that the people who get most mad
are the people who are a bit insecure
because they they don't really feel that
they know the the subject so um that's
an interesting thing you find that in in
his rhetoric if you want to uh look at
that it's a rhetoric book too
now um there is there is something
really beneficial to getting an Insider
perspective on um whether it's whether
it's worthwhile to engage in it and I'm
I'm actually going to you know say that
it's really a great idea to do some of
these things and probably not a great
idea to shoot for some of the other ones
um I I think I I can bring a sort of
objectivity to this about the nature of
the profession when it comes to at least
teaching philosophy um and and so
despite the fact that I I would love to
see more room for philosophy professors
I'm not going to tell you that that it's
actually a great uh career path at this
this point in time for somebody to to
set out on now that's very different
than whether you should major in
philosophy uh or or you know whether you
should go on to to do philosophy in
graduate school or whether a Philosophy
degree is worthwhile or or worthless
these are all separate questions and uh
I'm very you know positive on some and
rather negative on the others so um I
think it you can ask somebody who really
does appreciate philosophy obviously I
wouldn't be doing the kind of work that
I do if I didn't have a great
appreciation for
philosophy um I would have gotten out of
this business a long time ago
um you can ask somebody in a position
like that and get some some pretty
straight answers which is what I hope
I'm providing you with here does that
mean that that's going to be the case
can doesn't translate into will or will
in most cases or anything like that so
you might get some some bad answers from
other people and I think this is really
uh a major a significant issue because
there's a lot of young bright interested
students who who I think are getting bad
advice from people in Academia about
whether they should go on and pursue
Advanced degrees in Academia and I think
some of that is in fact self-serving on
the part of those or at least you know
not well informed on the part of those
those
academicians so um the other thing that
I wanted to talk about was before going
into these three questions was um you
know whether you can and so to speak get
ahead of the curve in terms of learning
philosophy on your own um even though
you don't have philosophy classes in in
your high school um now if if you don't
have philosophy classes in your high
school you're actually not unusual most
places don't um the the exceptions would
be for the most part religious schools
um where often you you can take it as a
uh religion elective um and it may be
good or it may be be terrible as a
matter of fact when I went to high
school I took a philosophy class that I
thought was terrible and then I ended up
having a religion class that wound up
turning into a philosophy class that I
thought was wonderful and that there's a
whole story there that I I've talked
about in other places um the other if
you're in a public school and they
actually have the money to do it so it's
mostly the rich schools that do this
then philosophy sometimes gets taught as
a social studies elective and that's
nice for the students that can afford it
but I I don't think that's the case in
in most schools here in the US which is
uh rather unfortunate it's not the case
in other places but we we just don't
value that in our our curriculum even
though we give a lot of lip service to
things like ethics and critical thinking
we don't bring in the people who are
actually experts in that to to teach
these sorts of things now um can you
study philosophy on your own you
definitely can and as a matter of fact
um you may depending on on your study
skills and uh the resources that you use
you might actually do better studying on
your own than taking some philosophy
classes with certain academic professors
um there's a wide range of quality when
it comes to teaching and by the way this
this doesn't map directly on to you know
the status of a school there are some
horrible teachers at Elite schools there
are some wonderful teachers at AT
schools that seem to be the bottom of
the barrel and you know talent and and
uh Enterprise and willingness to work
with students seems to be more or less
distributed across the the board it's
very difficult to predict um every
school that that you you know Read
Literature on tells you that they're
doing a wonderful job um and you know if
you go and do a tour those tour guides
will generally tell you that their
school is is just amazing and you'll
study whatever but that's all just
fluffy um you don't actually know until
you you get there and start working with
people or or you get the inside dope so
to speak uh whether whether a uh
curriculum or a professor is going to be
any good so you can in fact study it on
your own I mean you can you can read
philosophy you know I'm just holding
this up as an example so here's
Aristotle's uh metaphysics books uh uh
10 through 14 the economics and the
Magnum moralia some people don't think
the econ economics and Magnum moralia
are by AR but I mean you can read this
stuff and study it and you can find a
lot of resources online um you know not
just not just me but many other people
talking about these sorts of things
teaching about them um and you can you
can learn a lot in the process I myself
you know I went to undergraduate and and
graduate school uh and I did take a lot
of classes but I also learned a lot of
what it is that I myself talk about on
my own um I I never took a class uh well
I'll let me let me put it this way I
never took a class in a philosophy
department on Aristotle that I got
anything out of I studied Aristotle on
my own um say the same thing about the
stoics too or or St anom who I've he's
the person I've done the most writing on
in the course of my career um there's a
lot you can do on your own that said you
do want to connect up with other people
who are interested in that sort of stuff
so now let's talk about these three
questions that I isolated out um that
are supposed to be the main content of
of this this uh little chat here so
you're a 16-year-old high school student
or or you know for more broadly anybody
else who's in a similar case you know uh
and the question is um should you major
in philosophy if you're interested in
philosophy and you're going to college
and I I would say um yes
you you should major in philosophy um
that's not to say that that would be
your only major I actually myself double
majored in philosophy and Mathematics
and I had to decide after I graduated
whether I was going to go on and do you
know um graduate work in in philosophy
or in mathematics or just you know work
on on studying for the Actuarial exams
that was another career path or perhaps
do some some other things instead um you
know if you if you major in philosophy I
think it's a great idea not just to
major in philosophy but to double major
double major and something else that you
are interested in uh because no matter
what you're doing in philosophy you're
going to find some overlaps even if you
do philosophy and business or
philosophy and art or philosophy and um
fizet education you will find ways in
which philosophy as a field permeates
these other things and and the you know
the the skill sets that you're learning
that are being emphasized in philosophy
with critical thinking with you know
paying attention to important ethical
questions with being able to make good
distinctions and and you know analyze
arguments uh knowing something about the
history of thought all of that is going
to inform what you do in other cases but
you know the other thing is if you
really do like philosophy and you're
offered the chance to major in it why
not do so you know now that may not be
the case at a lot of Institutions um the
place where I actually did my
undergraduate they no longer offer a
philosophy minor I actually taught at
another place uh fville State University
that only had a philosophy minor and
didn't have a major um where we mostly
taught critical thinking classes but you
find ways to make that interesting to to
bring in the kind of work that you want
to do the other thing to remember too is
um a lot of philosophy does not get done
in philosophy departments so I'll give
you an example if you're really
interested in Alexis to toille this very
important uh 19th century uh thinker um
you're probably not going to find him
taught in a philosophy Department you'll
probably find him in a political science
department uh as a matter of fact John
Stewart Mill who you will find being
taught in a philosophy Department
probably will get taught better in a in
a political science department than in
the philosophy Department in most places
um um Emanuel Kant will be taught in a
philosophy Department he'll also be
taught in some polyi departments and
some history departments and some some
other places uh and they may you know
work on complimentary aspects there's a
lot of great stuff you know um that that
gets taught in English departments uh or
in uh you know various studies
departments you know you might go to a
place that has a for example a Catholic
studies department and you find some of
the medieval philosophers being taught
by by them and not being taught by the
philosophy department or a women studies
Department you know you want to study
somebody who happens who happens to be
both a woman and a great philosopher
like say Simone deoir or Mary walstone
craft uh and they don't get taught in
the philosophy Department even if they
have a class on you know women in
philosophy or gender in philosophy uh
well they'll probably be taught in the
women's studies department so so there's
that but um should you major in
philosophy yeah you know it's great to
do so because you get some sort of
curriculum if if the philosophy
department is up to Snuff um there's a
lot of places where I suppose you know
if if it was my my kid asking me hey
should I go here I would look at the
department and I might
say I don't think you're going to get
that much out of studying with these
people but you have to evaluate that on
a caseby casee basis you have to see
what the people are interested in this
is one of the places too where I would
suggest that if you're considering
different schools and you're considering
majoring in philosophy this would also
go for any other major you want to
actually get to meet some of the people
who are going to be doing that teaching
you want to get to observe a class while
you're doing a a a visit to that campus
um so you know if you if you have the
possibility of doing that definitely
make that happen now um the next
question is a Philosophy degree
worthless this is actually a great
question to ask uh I think a lot of
people get get you know very upset when
you when you even suggest this to them
but that's because they're actually
afraid that the degree that they are uh
trying to Hawk to you is in fact
worthless a Philosophy degree is is
definitely not worthless and we'll put
it in a number of different ways I
mean you can say that anything that you
really want to study is worth studying
right but that's not what you're ask
asking about what you're asking about is
is not just sort of something uh about
intrinsic value you're asking about um
whether this degree will in fact help
you to to find some sort of remunerative
work that you find interesting and can
see yourself doing at least long enough
to pay off your probable student loans
and to have some sort of decent standard
of living and some uh you know Security
in your life um and that's really I
think a fair question to ask um I think
we're doing a terrible job in in telling
people um about about you know how that
that works in today's economy and how if
you're going to do something in
philosophy or in the humanities in
general you can in fact um turn that
into something that um Can can earn you
a living that that's really quite
important um
so to begin
with there's a lot of things that you
can in fact do with a Philosophy degree
because you can do something with
Humanity's degrees there's lots of
places that are going to hire you not
necessarily so you can tell them about
decart or Plato or you know do Socratic
questioning or anything like that
they're hiring you because by getting
that degree
you have hopefully acquired some skills
that employers are looking for when they
do um surveys of employers and they ask
them what it is that they want of
graduates critical thinking uh skills
are at the top being ethical is also
something at the top very difficult to
do if you've never actually given much
thought to ethics other than in
immediate situation
just to try to get it over with as
quickly as possible in philosophy we
actually study that if if again if your
professors are doing their job if the
curriculum is set up properly um
capacity to uh communicate effectively
in in writing very very important in the
Contemporary workplace um philosophy
tends to promote that quite well and why
because you have to uh read other
people's papers and then you have to
right research skills very important as
well uh something that you should be
acquiring if you're doing a Philosophy
degree so now you know it's not as if
you know you couldn't do that by doing a
history degree or by doing an English
degree or or something like that as well
but you know
philosophy tends to be in some respects
a little bit more rigorous uh than some
of these these other programs again
depending very much on where you're
going uh um you know there's other
aspects as well that you know one of the
best preparations for going to law
school is to do a Philosophy degree you
know polyi history those are pretty good
as well um philosophy Majors tend to
score very high in lsats on the gr um
now it could be that there's a little
bit of self- selection there but I like
to think that it's in part because of
the curriculum because of the things
that you're studying um because you're
you're taking in so much and perhaps
there's even a little a little bit of
because philosophy you know has such a
long history a little bit of uh
intellectual humility that we learn
along the way when we realize that we
cannot possibly assimilate all of this
sort of stuff so there's a lot of things
you can do with a Philosophy degree um
people are hiring Those Who come out of
school with philosophy degrees depending
on what you also emphasize um with a ba
you might be able to transition that
into a job as well so I wouldn't be you
know uh pessimistic about your capacity
with the Bachelors to get out into the
workplace and be competitive with a
Philosophy degree if you end up being
you know the kind of person who looks
down their nose at everybody else
because you've got a Philosophy degree
and they don't um you will not get hired
or if you do you will not get promoted
and you you probably won't stay in your
position long but that's more that has
really little to do with philosophy and
more to do with you know skills in
communicating with other people and
dealing with them and and uh you know
the kind of people who do that tend to
do that not not necessarily just because
they have a Philosophy degree but
because they have some other thing that
they hold over other people so that you
know I I doubt that's going to be the
case um given given you know the the
sensitivity that you're showing in in
writing this um but it is a legitimate
worri and the last thing I'll say along
these lines is I think it's also quite
legitimate for parents in hearing from
their son or daughter hey I want a major
in
philosophy um particularly if they don't
have a lot of um background in this sort
of thing or they've met some people who
who were you know philosophy professors
and were jerks uh or or you know majored
in philosophy and then were unemployed
later on um I think it's very reasonable
for them to say
that's fine son or daughter but how are
you going to get a job and not live in
my basement you know after you you would
do your four years when it comes to this
and I think there's good answers that
that can be given to them on that that
account so I think that's enough about
the second question let me answer the
third question now this is where you're
probably not going to be so happy to
hear what I have to say um should you
aim at being a philosophy professor
which means should you plan on going to
graduate school and not only earning a
master's but a
PhD um so you know extending your your
education another two plus four to five
years I know some people do finish their
phds in three years but trust me you
when you're actually in school you don't
want to try to rush school so should you
extend your your education by another
six to S years um with the hopes that
you're going to be teaching in a
classroom if this was two generations
ago I would say absolutely because the
job market was great back then that
would be for the people who were my
professors who remembered when a phone
call could get you in by the time that
that I was going on the job market in
the early
2000s um and and I knew a lot of people
who were already going on the market in
the late 90s you know because we would
chat with each other the job market was
pretty bad it got much much worse as the
2000s went on so you know we were going
from maybe there's 100 people applying
for the position that you're applying
for some of whom are professors who
already have jobs and are trying to
trade up some of whom have gone to much
better schools so they look better on
paper than you some of whom have letters
of recommendation from Big names in the
profession um we went from that to now
now there's 500 applicants for the job
that you're looking for and um many of
them are on the you know the the circuit
looking for jobs uh for for years and
years uh many of them with degrees from
from a leaded
institutions um it's quite tough and so
for the present day students they're in
a very difficult situation and I you
know have a lot of sympathy for them and
I wouldn't
suggest that um
somebody deliberately decide my career
path is going to be college professor or
you know I I'll you know just find some
minimum wage job because it's it's just
not feasible in in the days when when I
and other people were were making that
that decision it was a lot easier to
find jobs um people weren't spending as
great a proportion of their income in
General on housing and on Health Care um
there wasn't as much uncertainty about
things and um I know that it's it's a
really attractive Prospect to be a
professor because you look at them and
it looks like their lives are really
great and I'm not going to actually
knock it some of them actually do have
quite you know cush positions but
they're in the
minority um you know the people at the
research institutions they're teaching
one to two classes per semester some of
them teaching one class a year and
they're getting paid and they're they're
doing research and they're publishing
and probably their school is paying for
them to go to conferences and stuff like
that um most of the people in four-year
teaching colleges or in not so
well-funded you know bigger State
schools are teaching four classes each
semester they're doing a lot of
committee work um they're getting paid
maybe to go to one conference per year
if there's still any funding left for
that um it's you know many of them go
for years without seeing any pay
increases and they may be hired at at
you know fairly
unfortunate uh rates to begin with uh
and then there's this whole pool of
people who are adjuncting and you know
adjuncting is great if you don't need to
do it if you're if you're a person who
can make it without without having to
add junct and you want to teach a class
here or there that's that's wonderful
right if you have to do it as a way of
earning a living it's pretty hard and I
would you know I I wouldn't wish it on
anybody um it it takes a real toll on
not only your body and your mind but
also your emotional life your
relationships um it it sets you behind
as far as being able to pay off student
loans
you know establish a stable lifestyle
I've known other people too who have
gone from temporary position full-time
position to another one to another one
and it you know this this sounds like
really very you know boring adult stuff
but you're unable to actually uh save
any money by doing that because you have
to move and relocate every two years so
becoming a philosophy Professor should
you know should you go into that that's
you know that's that's really uh quite
tough right now and I I would say that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't go
necessarily to graduate school but you
should plan on doing something else
maybe you're going to work in a library
maybe you're going to you know do
something else with philosophy and
you're going to find some way to get
some some corporate clients to hire you
to do some some Consulting with them on
ethics maybe you're going to be the
ethicist for a hospital um there's a lot
of more practical stuff other than just
being being in a teaching position that
if you're going to go to graduate school
I think it's it's very important to to
consider um now the other thing that I
want to say to bring this to a close you
don't have to worry about that question
about going to graduate school and
becoming a professor when you're
thinking about should I major as an
undergraduate in
philosophy you see those are two
separate
things um I understand that you know if
you're coming from a background where
you don't know a lot of people who who
did uh major in philosophy I I came from
a similar background I didn't know a
hell of a lot of people uh in my family
who actually went to college uh in you
know until later on in My Generation
Um it makes sense that you would think
that well you're going to go ba ma PhD
and then teach um but there's plenty of
opport OPP unities to get your ba and
then do something and keep on studying
keep on doing things on the side we have
this great you know internet with all
these resources and those resources
aren't just for carrying on studied by
yourself there are meetup groups you can
you can find people who want to do
philosophy uh and want to talk about it
um you know some of them more serious
some of them less serious but all over
the world you can you can be part of an
intellectual community in ways that just
were not possible you know 15 years ago
when when I was you know newly Minted as
a as a PhD um so I think there's you
know this this issue of should you major
in philosophy you should consider that
totally independent about this this
notion about like becoming a professor
later on so hope that's helpful not only
for the the student who's asking me this
question but for other people who are in
similar circumstances and for those of
you who aren't hope this was interesting
for you and uh yeah those are my
thoughts on on the subject I'm sure
other people have plenty of other
perspectives you can put those in the
comments if you want to um and uh we
we'll see what what people have to say